i'm gonna hit the break room does
anybody want anything
bam you good yeah sure okay
i have the best stocked survival shelter
in northeastern pennsylvania but
everything has a shelf life
so i must eat and then replace
everything that's about to expire
it's nice not to have to plan my meals
you're eating
eight-year-old tomatoes they're still
good for another week you know i think i
might have some type of cheese in the
back of my fridge you might like
i've got some cheese you might like too
in between my toes
all right picture this snowy ash
drizzles from the sky
a rabid pack of dogs surrounds you as
the flame at the end of your stick dies
out
there's only one hope left for you the
door to my shelter you pound
you beg dwight please let me in but i
ignore your cries and do not let you in
you want to know why because of the sign
that says no pounding no begging no
because you laughed at me
kevin will be eaten pam will be taken
slave
jim will be made a warlord's jester
meredith will do okay
be assured this day will come it's just
a matter of time could be one month
could be two months three months could
be
four months i could see that happening
yes eight months that's a realistic
timeline
11 months perhaps
okay wait now really think hard about
this one
one year i could see that as a very real
possibility
494 months i could see that happening
495 months that's just
i have recently taken a lover well
that's great congratulations
who's the lucky lady pam's mom
what pam's mom helene remember from your
wedding
you're messing with me about what you
did not have sex with pam's mom
oh big time what kind of cars to drive
she drives a green camera
and the seats go all the way down all
the way down oh my god
oh my gosh what okay
never tell pam and then secondly good
packed
a packed although i may have to break it
tonight when helene and i tell pam over
dinner
you all right oh my god hey jim
not now toby my god get the hell out of
here idiot
what did i do okay as far as dinner
tonight
cancel that and please for both of our
sakes never
ever ever see her again i think you're
underestimating pam
i think more than anything she wants me
to be happy no
not more than anything okay i i have a
good thing
with the mom don't call her she's right
on my way home from work then take a
different way home man
all right i'll take surface streets it's
the last thing in the world i would want
to do is upset pam okay
so we're good yeah
i drink like a hundred iced macchiatos a
day and practically nothing else
wow there's a really cool coffee place
jitters
at the steamtown mall you've been there
no
you've never been to jitters ryan you
are so dorky
give me your number so i can text you
um come on
can i have an email address but i just
thought you should know
i think something a little fishy is
going on a little fishy
yeah i mean i've been noticing all day
that little girl is a child i don't want
to see you sniffing around her
anymore this afternoon do you understand
boy have you lost your mind cause i'll
help you
find it what you're looking for ain't
nobody gonna help you out there jesus
can come through that door and he's not
gonna help you
if you don't stop sniffing after my
child okay
hey hello
jim what's up buddy this is not funny
why is my stuff in here
wow that's weird ooh dollar for stapler
that's pretty good yeah well i'm not
paying for my own stuff
okay i know you did this because you're
friends with the vending machine guy oh
steve
that's my pencil cup um i don't think so
i just bought it
uh i think so and you're going to hand
it over to me
i love these okay fine
oh there it is j1
here you know i don't know how many
okay i have an announcement you pushed
daryl out the window no i'm shot dwight
no
no that is not funny i love my employees
even though i hit one of you with my car
for which
i take full responsibility look i'm just
trying to take everybody's mind off of
this unavoidable
tragedy and onto more positive things
so i thought we should plant a tree
oh good at least we don't have to work
okay we're leaving for the hospital at
one so
like a freedom tree i can take three
people i can also take three people
separate cars pam all right we'll get a
card at the hospital and we'll sign it
outside our room
pam sales people can go later in the day
hourly workers can go at lunch
okay good good so we'll just all go down
there together at lunch
excellent i was thinking good work pam
but if yay
all right since i am the boss i will
drive as well who wants shotgun
you can't be serious you ran a woman
over this morning everyone inside the
car
was fine stanley
that's interesting wow it's a little
early for ice cream
it's never too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
god oscar toby and i are founding
members of the finer things club
we meet once a month to discuss books
and art celebrate culture
in a very civilized way sometimes the
debate can get
heated but we're always respectful
there is no paper no plastic and no work
talk aloud it's very exclusive
besides having sex with men i would say
the finer things club is the gayest
thing about me
so tell me again why i can't be a part
of your club because some people think
that you monopolize the conversation by
trying to be funny
oscar some people
found him jim we're getting crapped on
word is our branch sucks and we have to
do something about it so what are you
gonna do
what are we gonna do we are going to
make a monster sail is what we're going
to do
corcoran dropped staples did they yes
they did oh yes they did and we are
going to
murder it you me dwight are going to
jump in my pt cruiser
we are going to crush this sale we are
going to prove
what the hell is that music it's vivaldi
for finer things that's the problem
that's the problem we need
rock and roll pam rock and roll all
right
oh my
god that's why people are leaving
i i have no words
oh god that tickles what i want someone
to follow donna
i want her tailed i need the name of a
good private investigator
i think i've got one for you
this is you how much you charge 100 a
day plus expenses i'll give you 50.
money's no object
done i'm just gonna warn you and i say
this to all my clients
you might not like what i find okay and
you might not like
how i find it
how can he still not know we can't
figure that out i can't take it anymore
wait what you can't take what i am
telling andy no
you can't do that it shouldn't come from
you who should have come from then
answer your love for
angela angela are you still having
intercourse with her
what is wrong with you she is engaged
did you ever have intercourse in this
office
are you serious ugh
where where
where dwight seems like you already know
where
hey are your little dudes crawling yet
no three-month-old humans don't do that
my philip is crawling
angela is such a liar it's maddening
exactly that's just like crate training
all night long
all night long well count yourself lucky
wait until you have two
that's two sleep schedules two naps that
don't coincide i mean you'll never sleep
again
no one said you must have two like her
genes are so important
the world just needs more pam gym dna
thank you no no
thank you
[Laughter]
check this out my brother just got a new
sailboat he has no idea
what he just got himself into there's
nothing harder than taking care of a
boat
am i right unbelievable unbelievable
you